l'actualité aujourd'hui procède par
rafale après plus de quinze jours d'
enquête
voilà qu'on apprend qu'un cousin du père
du petit grégory découvert ligoté et
noyé le 16 octobre dernier près d'epinal
c'est un vient d'être placé en garde à
vue après enquête des gendarmes sur
place a pris hier isabelle bechler
première inculpation en vue dans
l'enquêté sur le meurtre de grégory
bernard laroche 26 ans cousin germain de
jean marie le père de l'enfant
il est ouvrier qualifié dans une
filature de la commune d'hautmont c'est
à une quinzaine de kilomètres de
lépanges depuis le jour du crime bernard
laroche sa femme et sébastien à leur
petit garçon de 5 ans l'hiver plus
derrière leurs volets affirmant même
qu'il avait peur pour l'enfant bernard
laroche a été confondu par les analyses
graphologiques les lettres de menaces
aux villemin et la lettre de
revendication du crime serait bel et
bien écrite de sa main
le mobile serait la jalousie dans le
voisinage de la roche
on ne comprend pas c'est vraiment la
stupeur
qu'est ce qui lui a pris
ne fallait qu'ils aient des histoires et
s'entendent pas en famille mais pas au
point l'armé main doit pas se bagarrer
entre hommes 1 comme ça se fait partout
il y en a pas des familles a pas
d'histoire est on arrivé là
non mais quelle honte
alors bernard laroche était interpellé
les gendarmes reconstituer une fois de
plus l'assassinât de l'enfant à l'aide
d'un mannequin dans la vologne
mais il faudra attendre l'audition du
suspect pour savoir s'il avait des
conflits et qu'il était la question que
tout le monde se pose sans doute en voie
d'être élucidée pourquoi un enfant de 4
ans a payé de sa vie une peine d'adulte